(Sharply exhales)
Apology video time
I've made a severe lapse in my judgement
I have no excuses here today
i have no idea
how I'm gonna record this video dude
JAMES CHARLES
legendary apology to
TATI
now with 47 million views
gOdDaAmMnN
up on its way to becoming
the most viewed apology video
of all time
almost beating Logan Paul's
So Sorry for my severe lapse of judgment
55 million views
I bet Logan is actually hurt about that dammit
My apology video isn't number 1
most people would be like "oof, finally, people moved onto another"
I don't know I'm just joking
anyway ehhh *funny laugh*
now I think it's safe to say that people didn't like this apology video
not just from losing what is it now, over 3 million subscribers
but for having 3 million dislikes on the video
and I always say just come to me
if you need to make an apology video just come to me
so this doesn't happen alright
WhEn WiLl YoU lEaRn
*higher pitch* WhEn WiLl YoU lEaRn
so, therefore, we will go through what's wrong with this apology video and what's right about it
*whispering* spoilers, not much
so without further ado
TEA TIME YAYYY TEA TIME
*giggling like a child* hehehehe hEE-hEe
Hi all
Now James is doing the classic 'I'm just gonna turn on the camera and talk for 8 minutes'
Which I can appreciate in the sense of at least, you know, he doesn't have a script,
He's just speaking his emotions
But at the same time... you have a lot of people angry James.
You want to be clear and concise on what you're gonna say.
Generally if you want to get a message across, any message ok, the number 1 rule of information is,
The easier the message is to say, the quicker it will spread.
Right?
And to just turn on the camera and 'blah blah blah' isn't gonna do that.
Ok!
james: James here. um. i'm currently travelling abroad and just woke up
but i wanted to sit down and make a video addressing everything that's going on right now
um...
OK so far we're 15 seconds in and he's said nothing that we can't already tell by just watching this video.
alright
you just woke up?
hey guys I just woke up
from my hair
can u tell??
even though I apparently sleep with earrings on
So that makes no sense.
james: i owe everybody an explanation but most importantly i owe two important people an apology.
to Tati and James
Westbrook
I'm sorry. for everything that is going on/everything that i've put you through over the past few weeks.
*felix laughing* he looks like he's about to sneeze
What is that?
ehh that's great
james: over the past few weeks.
*pewds laughing again*
I love that.
God damn he speaks slowly.
aGAIN, If you want  the message across, you Might wanna Be a little Quicker!
So he apologized to Tati, which in a way it's big of him to do
But at the same time it just kind of reaffirms everything she said
You know if you make a mistake, apologizing is the right thing to do without a doubt
But if you made a mistake with someone else, when people don't really know what happened,
to just flat out apologize seems to me like everything they said was right.
james: I met Tati and James almost three years ago now
when I was first coming into the industry and when I had no friends and nobody to talk to or look up to
and Tati very quickly took on a parental role with me
because she knew my parents were across the country, and....
come on James
I think another thing worth mentioning here is that this video has MORE views than Tati's video
so I understand that he's trying to explain some context behind the situation, of how he met Tati,
what if you don't know who Tati is?
It is just so bad
james: a lot of my-- most of my career over the past few years has been about me making mistakes
and trying to learn and grow from them
and I haven't always done the best job of that
Hey James,
I guess we're not so different, you and I.
Can't really be too harsh on him
*chuckles*
james: Um, but I haven't always tried.
.....
WELL TRY HARDER!!
I was really curious about James' past controversies because I don't know anything about him
But Tati said something about his Ebola scandal
so
What did he do
This was last year. "I can't believe we are going to Africa today omg what if we get Ebola"
"James we're fine we could've gotten it at chipotle last year"
..whut..?
WHAT
let's keep watching.
james: I know there's a lot of people watching me and that a lot of people look up to me as a role model
and I- I- I hate
knowing that I disappointed
not only them but most importantly
two people that have been role models to me.
doing this.
um...
I wish I could say that this is the last time I would make a mistake
but it won't be
*laughing* god
What a train wreck [lmao]
You know, if you're gonna apologize, maybe it's not best to lead with
"I'm gonna make more mistakes guys"
Like, before anyone's even seen that you have made any effort to improve that you've made to improve
"I'm still gonna make more mistakes guys!"
This is just adding more fuel to the flame at this point.
'I'd be lying if I said I'm still gonna make some oopsies, guys'
I know that I'll disappoint people
more and more as I continue to learn and grow every single day
I have a long way to go
a very long way to go
*laughing*
I like how he -- it seems like he catches himself smiling there
and then he's like "oh god. I need to follow up with a *slow exhale*"
james: very long way to go
*slow exhale*
HERE'S where you say, "I'm still gonna make mistakes," After you've acknowledged that you're trying to improve.
Not before!
Jesus Christ!
james: and be the best version of me that I possibly can be
I know I'm not perfect, I'm still gonna make mistakes
pewds: so stupid.
james: And I'm sorry. For that.
In regards to the Coachella situation, with the brand deal and the security guard,
I've already told my truth about this twice
um
and instead of
talking about it for a third time and explaining it and going into detail and pulling up receipts
it doesn't matter.
iT DoESN't mAttER
it.. does matter, James
I've tried my best to look into this drama, I have no idea what happened okay
People don't know what happened so you might wanna address it, ok.?
Just because you've said it twice doesn't mean that everyone's already heard it ok?
Clearly you have a lot of new eyes on you here, you want to treat this video as if someone completely new to you,
who's only heard about you from this scandal,
and give the context from there!
Just saying that you've already explained it doesn't mean anything
james: I understand that no matter what I say--
And then he follows it up with probably the dumbest line he could say,
one of the dumbest lines I've heard, in an apology video
james: Um, and I understand that no matter what I say or do,
there's always gonna be people that don't believe me
and will think that I am lying.
YES!
Yes you're not wrong but why on God's Earth would you say that?!
That's like, insulting these people that you're trying to persuade in your apology!
*laughing*
You have all these new eyes on you
that are gonna look at you strictly critically,
and to say "it doesn't matter what I say you aren't not gonna believe me anywayy"
Like, yes technically you're not wrong.
People are very riled up right now and in a way it probably doesn't matter that much what he says
But at the same time to say that is such a dumb idea.
There's plenty of things like "yes, technically you're right, but to say that in this context is a bad idea".
is a BAD IDEA james
james: And that's okay.
um, at this point the truth ... really does not matter.
Even worse, following with "the truth doesn't matter"
you're all just so wrong about me
then tell us
tell us, people don't know, they haven't heard you talk about this
he talks about how, the boy situation
where he has been hitting on a bunch of straight people
he has been very public about this and he is saying i wish i wasn't public about it
instead of saying i wish i didn't do that he just says i didn't tell people i did that
GREAT IDEA!
James: boys have been a topic that i've talked a lot about on my social media journey
and it's a topic that i wish i hadn't
people think what you did was wrong , to say you wish you didn't tell people 'bout it
instead of acknowledging that what you did was wrong is really strange
James: but coincidentally enough Tati really was one of the people to sit me down
and tell me how it looked from the outside
James:Umm
and let me know,  hey talking to these boys might get you in trouble one day(OH BOY WAS SHE RIGHT)
and she is right
in regards to
so he just brushed through the whole boy situation without any acknowledgment of that being wrong
GOOD JOB!
James: My own mother, umm
Wut
James: I know you want to defend me and
*wat da hell laugh*
James: go off on comments but i ask that you
don't
W H Y  W H Y  W H Y
why are you addressing your mom
is this how he talks to his mom, they don't text each other, they don't call each other
they just talk through his Youtube channel
*confused laugh*
no matter what is anybody saying or commenting or talking about,
Mom I need you to know
*precious pewds laugh*
that youre the most important person in my life
sorry I know that this is not a laughing moment but it seems like he wanted to round this up on an emotional part
and bringing up your parents when you've disappointed
its obviously going to hit anyone really hard
that's just how I interpreted this I
can't understand why else he would just
bring up his parents maybe to get some
sympathy I don't know it's really weird
An apology video should be to the people you're apologizing to
and that you're an amazing mother
and I don't know what I would do without you
pewdiepie: Well she clearly didn't do a good job
james: and I'm so grateful for everything that you've done for me
and the lessons you have taught me
and..
and everything that you continue to do for me and my brother
and.. I need you to know that
I NEED YOU TO KNOW THAT
alright, ok, chill out james
and the same thing goes for Tati
as well
who is an amazing person
What goes to Tati? i already forgot what he said
he speaks so goddamn slowly
mY goD
Don't waste peoples time
I watched it-- oh it's 7 minutes, it feels like an hour
james: and truly does want the best for everyone around her
I wonder how many people actually watched the whole thing
I doubt many people did, its so boring
my GoD
I'm so disappointed in myself.. That I..
hurt her
*breathes*
pewdiepie: end the video james
james: um, a lot of times that I've had to address things in the past,
pewdiepie: ohmygod it keeps going
james: I've acted out of impulse
and I've gone off
ThEn WhaT the HeLL is ThiS
how is this not an impulse
a lot of other times I got in drama, I acted on impulse
You uploaded this the day after
This video did nothing but add more fuel to the flame.
you want to take at least one day off
for people to say what they need to say about you
so then you can come in.
and also for you, yourself to kind of take in whats going on
and not just immediately go in and "Oh, I'm sorry. It doesn't matter what I say. You're not gonna believe me anyway"
James: and try to pull receipts
or facts
or screenshots
and play the victim
he's probably too dumb to be able to do that anyway
I know that's kind of mean to say but
Tati's clearly way smarter than James
She's got more experience. There's no way even if you have the facts
that he would be able to pull that off
It's almost like he's just admitting defeat at this point.
The video goes on. I can't-- I can't literally actually not finish it
*chuckles*
Here's the thing: this video did nothing
now its been a couple day since it's been uploaded
like, what's going to be the follow up? He's  already said he's not going to address anything
because people aren't going to believe him anyway
so what is he going to do?
Now, people just added more and more rumors and speculations
because you didn't address ANY of it
And people are very confused as to what actually happened.
So he can't come back and just explain the situation
how IS he going to come back from this-- I don't know
And I think this is why this is such a terrible apology video
and also, literally all he had to do
in my opinion. If I was James Charles
The way I would've done it is to say.
Explain the context of your personality change
of you becoming this ugly faker
You can explain how very young. I became extremely succes-- no not extremely
that would be gloating but
I became very successful very quickly and that has had a very negative impact on my personality
and now that I've hurt people around me, I realize that
and that I'm so hurt that it took me this long to understand this
and then I'm going to take some time off to focus on rebuilding this relationships
and saving these relationships
and also taking time to focus on improving myself
because I know that's what I need to do now more than anything
I'm sorry to everyone that I hurt and I'm sorry to everyone that I disappointed
At least then, you've said these things
you've acknowledge that what you did was wrong and that you're going to improve
and then when you come back, you have something to come back to
I don't know how James is going to come back from this
I think this actually could be the end. I don't know
He's still so young, however, and people don't tend to care about these things for too long
so, I think he'll be fine
But, I think, again, another testimony of
how you express yourself in a controversy would
massively affect
your career
it could make it worse or it could make it better
this one definitely made it worse.
Which is why
you should come to me.
Now I know I'm joking about like
"Oh, you should come to me about apology videos"
and that might seem like I'm super
calculative about my apology videos
I think luckily I've been able to speak in an honest way
and I think that also matters more than anything
But when you have so many emotions going
when you're in the middle of a controversy like this
it's easy to get sidetracked
and and confused about what you're doing
What do you think about this apology
Smash, like, subscribe if you haven't
and I'll see you guys next time
Bye
What? You never played Tuber Simulator
You know it's fun, right?
I'm not supposed to give my opinion
but give it a try
and then you can tell me if it's good or not
Not convinced yet? Okay
I'll cut you a deal
The game is available for free
and that's a great price!